Daoist for example they represent the
world in terms that are quite similar to
those that I just described for you so
the the doubt central now assemble is
this one the end yang symbol and yang
basically stands for order that's what
it means but it means all the things
that I've listed there it means order
masculinity the daytime the known it
also means authoritarianism and fascism
and then yen on the opposite side is
chaos femininity the night the unknown
decadence and nihilism and it's also a
relationship between the conscious and
unconscious the core consciousness is
represented by light and the reason for
that is well when are you conscious
you're conscious during the day right
because we're we're we're creatures that
live in the day unlike rats for example
you know they live at night so for us
consciousness is associated with
enlightenment and illumination and
daytime and sunrise and them and the
bright noon sky and the unconscious is
associated with the nighttime the reason
for that partly too is that your
unconscious is actually a lot more
active at night first of all that's when
you dream and it's also the time when if
you're frightened of something or if
you're depressed and ruminative the
frightening thoughts and the depressing
and ruminative thoughts are going to
come up so many many people have the
experience of waking up caught in a kind
of quasi cold sweat at 3:00 in the
morning and having you know nothing but
a continual stream of worries run
through their head and there's pretty
good evidence that a lot of what you're
doing at night when you sleep when
you're dreaming in when you're not
dreaming is actually processing threat
you know but most of the time you're
asleep for that sometimes you wake up
during it and it's like yeah it's not
something you really want to be
conscious about you know it's it's hard
on you and it's very very common among
people who are depressed you know so if
you want to diagnose someone for
depression one of the things you ask
them is well is your sleep chopped-up
you know do you wake up multiple times
at night and when you wake up what
happens and if they say well you know I
have worries running through my head and
I can't stop them
that's rumination because it's it's an
automatic process it's an unconscious
process then you know that the balance
between positive and negative emotion
has shifted too far for that person
there's so much chaos and pain in their
life
or their their emotional systems have
become dysregulated that it's starting
to pop up into consciousness and
dominate it so now the in yang symbol is
interesting for a variety of other
reasons too because the taoist believed
that that symbol represents being now
being is not the same thing as objective
reality being is what you experience as
a conscious creature that's being and
for the Taoist being is made up of these
two elements order and chaos and the
reason for that it's quite
straightforward the reason for that is
wherever you go and whenever you live
and whoever you are each environment
that you're in is composed of things you
understand and things that work the way
you expect them to and things you do not
understand and that can be that can pull
the rug out from you at any moment and
so you can say in some sense that these
symbolic representations are
representations of the most unchanging
elements of being so the most real
things because you know a typical modern
person look at this and think well those
aren't real it's like they are real in
fact they're hyper real because one of
the things that defines real is that
it's permanent and it is permanent no
matter where you go there are things you
know and things you don't know and it
doesn't matter who you are it's
permanent so it's part of the
existential landscape of human being now
the other thing that's there's two other
things that are quite cool about the
yin-yang symbol and one is that the each
of the the black pays he has a little
white dot in it and the white Paisley
has a little black dot in it and the
reason for that is the Daoists also
recognized quite well that chaos could
turn to order at any moment you know so
a new order can arise out of a chaotic
structure that's like a that's a
revolution in some sense but by the same
token if you're in a place that's
orderly and predictable something can
happen that casts you into a chaotic
situation right away so there's a
dynamic even though these two things
oppose each other in some sense there's
a continual dynamic interplay between
them and then the final thing that's
quite interesting about this symbol this
is a mind-boggling Lee brilliant idea is
that because the dao also means the way
and the way is the line between the two
and so what that indicates is
is a brilliant idea is that the optimal
position for a human being isn't in
chaos or in order because if it's too
much order then it's totalitarian and if
it's too much chaos then its disgust and
fear and emotional pain and depression
so where's the proper place and the
Daoist answer is right on the line where
you have one foot in order so that
you're fairly stable and you have
another foot in chaos so that new and
interesting and compelling and
transforming things are happening to you
and one of the things that you might
note is that your nervous system
basically tells you when you're there
and the way it tells you is by making
you interested in whatever it is that
you're engaged in because the fact that
the thing that you're engaged in grips
you which is really an unconscious
process you can't really control that
it's something that happens to you is
because your nervous system which is
actually adapted to the environment of
chaos and order is telling you that if
you're engaged and interested you are at
in the place where the balance between
chaos and order is is perfect now you
think about that it's no use reading a
paper that you cannot understand at all
even though hypothetically that would be
a tremendously informative paper right
but you can't understand it because it's
all chaos to you and then there's
absolutely no reason reading a paper the
tenth time if you've already extracted
the information out of it it's going to
be boring okay so what do you want well
you want a paper that you can almost
understand so there's you know your the
frameworks the cognitive frameworks that
you have at hand are sufficient for you
to take the next step into the unknown
and the paper will will inform you of
that and so those are the sorts of
things books do that movies do that
conversations do that even lines of
thought do that if they're exactly at
the right level of complexity for you
they're going to engage you and people
know this man they know it so here's an
example